dr. 1549 runway Sully Sully where are
you
no one warned us
no one said you are going to lose both
engines at a lower altitude than any jet
in history
this was dual-engine loss at 2,800 feet
followed by an immediate water landing
with 155 souls on board no one has ever
trained for an incident like that
our job is to investigate how a plane
ended up in the Hudson River all duds
it's not a crash was a forced water
landing simulations showed that you can
make it back to the airport not possible
I felt it go my aircraft bureaucrat I'm
gonna know I did the best I could of
course you did
she saved everyone people call you a
hero I don't feel like a hero
there's been too much talking to press
already I'm overwhelmed by all this
attention the left engine was still
operating with funding at this room who
find dangered the lives of all those
passengers I got an a320 diving for the
ribbon you did everything you could it's
more than enough
when's your last drink Atmos Homburg
have you had any troubles at home
this is the captain
brace for impact
yeah
there were people of that place
we were one of them over 40 years in the
air but in the end I'm gonna be judged
on 208 seconds passengers and there's
anyone still here
you
you